[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat en direct d'orléans on se tient
toute la journée
le congrès des régions de france le
rassemblement annuel des présidents de
région congrès qui a lieu en présence
d'edouard philippe le premier ministre
et ce congrès est bien il se tient dans
un contexte de grogne des élus locaux
suite aux annonces du gouvernement
touchant les collectivités territoriales
une grogne qui s'est d'ailleurs illustré
dimanche dernier lors des élections
sénatoriales
des élections qui ont vu la droite
conforté sa majorité la république en
marche régler c'est bien loin de la
percée espérée et cette grogne des élus
locaux elle s'est amplifié chez les
présidents de région vendredi dernier
lorsqu'ils ont appris que le fonds de
développement économique de 450 millions
d'euros que leur avait accordé manuel
valls l'an dernier étaient supprimés
dans le budget 2010 8 un véritable casus
belli pour philippe richert et les
régions de france la suppression de ce
fonds nous ne pouvons pas la comprendre
et ne pouvons pas nous résoudre à
l'accepter a d'ailleurs dit ce matin
philippe richert à edouard philippe
edouard philippe qui est donc venu
ouvrir ce congrès des régions de france
il y à quelques minutes pour tenter de
répondre à la grogne de ses élus locaux
de ses présidents de région et surtout
tenter de calmer leur colère
je vous propose tout de suite d'écouter
son discours en intégralité il a
prononcé dans ce théâtre d'orléans il ya
quelques instants
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président cher philippe
monsieur le maire sheikh livier monsieur
président du conseil régional sert
muriel pénicaud mesdames et messieurs
les présidents de conseils régionaux
l'oms et messieurs les parlementaires
mesdames et messieurs pour tous les
français orléans est associé à un
imaginaire glorieux vous avez dit
monsieur le maire le rôle central qui
avait joué jeanne d'arc dans ma
réputation l'image la fierté que cette
ville évoque pour tous les français je
voudrais commencer mon intervention en
parlant de celui qui a le plus
directement bénéficié de cette opération
charles vii charles vii
devenu droit en 14 129 est finalement
assez peu connu il mériterait de l'être
plus mériteraient de l'être plus car il
fait partie de cette longue liste de
souverains trop méconnu mais qui milieu
du 15e siècle vont poser les bases de ce
qui devient l'état moderne
on imagine souvent que la construction
de l'état en france passe par un effort
univoque constant d'une centralisation
qui mettrait tout à sa main et qui
garantirait un état fort et donc une
france constituée c'est souvent un peu
plus fin que ça un peu plus dual je
n'irai pas que charles vii faisait du en
même temps ce serait un contresens
historique
il faut toujours se méfier mais nous
pouvons observer dans les décisions
qu'il prend un mouvement subtil entre
d'un côté des mesures avisé unificatrice
c'est le cas des réformes des finances
qu'il engage la fiscalité l'armée des
coutumes mais d'un autre côté charles
vii multiplient les centres de pouvoirs
territoriaux avec l'établissement où la
confirmation de parlement de province à
toulouse à grenoble à bordeaux à dijon
ou encore plus intéressant
l'établissement d'une cour des aides qui
à montpellier tiendra compte du régime
fiscal propre au pays de langue d'oc
si vous permettez de reprendre les
termes d'un auteur un médiéviste
français qui s'appelle leonardo fang il
produit récemment une passionnante étude
sur l'espace politique français entre
395 115 la monarchie se rencontrent à
l'époque je cite que le principal danger
qui la menace n'est plus l'autonomie des
provinces mais leur anémie et c'est
pourquoi elle s'attache non seulement à
préserver
mais même à renforcer leurs prérogatives
l'histoire de france mesdames et
messieurs est ainsi elle a toujours
oscillé entre la volonté pour solidifier
l'état de centraliser et la nécessité de
prendre en compte l'incroyable diversité
de ses territoires de leur histoire de
leurs spécificités
vous connaissez la formule de françois
mitterrand la france ait eu besoin d'un
pouvoir fort et centralisé pour ce faire
elle a aujourd'hui besoin d'un pouvoir
décentralisé pour ne pas se défaire
le seul reproche que je ferais à cette
formule c'est d'imaginer qu'il puisse y
avoir un mouvement de balancier
alors qu'en vérité il faut qu'il y ait
une tension permanente entre ces deux
éléments de l'histoire française
pour que notre pays puisse pleinement
s'épanouir et le gouvernement que je
dirige s'inscrit dans cette double
dynamique
nous sommes convaincus qu'il faut à la
fois rénové l'échelon central pour lui
rendre son agilité pour le concentré sur
les missions que personne d'autre ne
prendra à sa charge pour qu'il soit en
hameaux à la hauteur des enjeux de notre
temps et nous devons en même temps
permettre à des régions et à des
territoires d'être à la fois solide et
bien vivant de s'épanouir et de
prospérer et c'est précisément dans cet
esprit que le 17 juillet dernier
j'ai ouvert la confession la conférence
nationale des territoires laquelle
participer et
monsieur le président de la république
et au cours de laquelle il a prononcé un
discours remarqué dont vous avez fait et
à monsieur le président tout cela était
organisé au sénat l'objectif de la
conférence nationale des territoires
quel est il les jeux le rappel de
pouvoir et discuter en amont de toute
décision affectant les collectivités
territoriales il est de favoriser
l'exercice d'une décentralisation
assumer agile et intelligente
il est pour reprendre les mots du
président de la république
probablement cher au président rousset
de nouer avec vous des pactes girondins
il est donc en hameau de dialoguer c'est
la raison de la présence ce matin je
sais combien votre association tient à
ce dialogue et surtout disons le
monsieur le président à un dialogue
privilégié entre les régions et le
gouvernement
j'y suis moi même très sensible c'est la
raison pour laquelle le j'ai répondu
sans hésitation à votre invitation ce
matin et c'est la raison pour laquelle
je suis heureux d'être ici avec madame
pénicaud je sais également les attitudes
de qu'a pu susciter parmi certains chez
vous le lancement de cette conférence
nationale des territoires avec la
crainte que cette instance est logique
ce processus ne vienne remettre en cause
la relation bilatérale à laquelle vous
tenez tant je vous le dis clairement ce
ne sera pas le cas le dialogue que nous
aurons le cadre le dialogue que nous
aurons dans le cadre de cette conférence
sera complémentaire de celui que nous
pourrons continuer d'avoir par ailleurs
sur des sujets qui vous concernent
exclusivement et ils sont nombreux
il faut que les régions participent à la
conférence nationale des territoires
parce que certains sujets exige que tous
les territoires réfléchisse ensemble et
dialoguent ensemble et il faut plier par
ailleurs une discussion bilatérale entre
l'état et les régions pour les sujets
qui concernent spécifiquement
exclusivement les régions où sur
lesquelles elles ont un rôle extrêmement
particulier
n'est donc pas question avec cette
conférence de diluer le débat il est
question de l'enrichir il est également
question de traiter les sujets de
manière franche transparente
guidé par le seul souci commun de servir
au mieux des intérêts des français
parmi ces sujets il en est un qui a
suscité des incompréhensions pour ne pas
dire des frictions c'est le contenu du
projet de loi de finances pour 2010 8
qui a été présenté hier par le ministre
de l'action des comptes publics monsieur
gérald darmanin
je voudrais donc prendre le temps d'y
revenir en me tenant aux faits et d'y
revenir le plus directement possible
lorsque nous sommes arrivés aux
responsabilités en mai dernière qu'avons
nous trouver dans le budget 2010 est une
série de promesses
d'engagement dont les financements
n'étaient pas toujours garanti ça n'est
pas moi qui le dit ou plus exactement ce
n'est pas seulement moi qui disais c'est
la cour des comptes elle avait été
l'élaboration du budget à la fin 2016
formulée elle n'était pas la seule
des doutes sur la réalité voire sur la
sincérité ses objectifs qui étaient
annoncés au regard des engagements qui
étaient pris au moment de la préparation
du budget en 2016 vous vous souvenez
monsieur le président vous êtes attentif
à ces sujets que l'objectif affiché
c'était un déficit de 2,7 pour cent du
pib
il a été corrigés au fur et à mesure
qu'on avançait dans les débats pour
faire preuve de plus de réalisme sans
doute à 2 8% du produit intérieur brut
et lorsque nous avons demandé à la cour
des comptes de nous dire ce qu'il en
serait pour l'année 2010 est compte tenu
de ce qui avait été promis de ceux qui
avaient été engagées de ce qui avait été
budgété
la cour nous a dit au début du mois de
juillet que loin du 2,8 affiché nous
arriverions dans l'exécution du budget à
3,2 si et seulement si le gouvernement
prenait des mesures énergiques
ça c'est la réalité sont les faits
en rappelant ces faits je ne veux pas
dire que ceux qui nous ont précédés ont
failli parce que dans le cours des
choses
c'est toujours facile de dire après
qu'on aurait dû faire différemment avant
je dis simplement qu'à partir du mois de
mai et qu à partir de l'audit réalisé
par la cour des comptes au mois de
juillet nous avons eu la certitude la
certitude
objectivement et indépendant
indépendamment en tout cas avec beaucoup
d'indépendance présenté que bien que les
finances de la france n'étaient pas
bonnes
vous avez cité monsieur le président
molière le malade n'est pas imaginaire
et seuls les tartuffes peuvent en juger
autrement
il a donc fallu prendre des décisions et
nous les avons prises la première
décision que nous avons prise parce
qu'elle correspondait un engagement de
campagne que c'est également assez
important de tenir les engagements de
campagne
ça a été de ne pas augmenter les impôts
en 2017
et après tout il aurait été possible de
le faire il aurait même été facile de le
faire ça c'est déjà fait ça s'est déjà
vu
pour équilibrer quelque chose qui part
assez loin de l'objectif initial on
augmente les impôts en cours d'année et
on rattrape d'une certaine façon la
difficulté comme cela
nous n'avons pas voulu utiliser cet
instrument parce que nous nous étions
engagés à ne pas le faire nous avons
donc mis en place dès l'année 2010 est
des économies des réductions de dépenses
des réductions de dépenses souvent
impopulaires les assume
parce qu'il fallait le faire et parce
que nous terminons grâce à cette
réduction de dépenses grâce à cette
annulation grâce à six
pardon grâce à ces annulations de
crédits ou grâce à ses économies
nous terminerons l'année 2017 dont la
cour nous avait dit qu'elle serait
marquée par une exécution à 3,2 pour
cent si et seulement si nous prenions
des mesures énergiques
nous terminerons en dessous des 3%
probablement aux alentours de 2,9
ensuite qu'avons nous fait nous avons
préparé le budget 2010 huit ans nos
fictions comme objectif de tenir les
engagements pris par le président de la
république et nous avons consulté
largement nous avons consulté le
président les régions france philippe
richert et lors de ces échanges
monsieur le président lors de ces
échanges tonique
car vous connaissez tous le caractère
tonique du président reichardt lorsqu il
le défend les intérêts des régions à
juste titre d'ailleurs
apportez à votre crédit monsieur le
président
c'est tonique
le président richert tu nous as dit tout
l'attachement des régions de france à
l'affectation d'une ressource fiscale
dynamique
c'était la ligne rouge
vous avez vous dit c'était une
revendication ancienne et c'était une
revendication ancienne à laquelle nos
prédécesseurs avaient donné droit dans
le cadre de la loi de finances votée en
2016 pour l'année 2010 est avec une
échéance au 1er janvier 2018 compte tenu
de la situation budgétaire du pays et de
la nécessité de redresser les comptes
publics
revenir sur cette promesse aurait pu
être une option
nous ne l'avons pas fait nous confirmons
donc trois désengagement du gouvernement
précédent en 2018
la dotation globale de fonctionnement
des régions sera bien transformer en une
fraction de tva j'ai tenu à ce que cette
dynamique de la tva soit garanti aux
régions pour les cinq prochaines années
ce qui représente plus plus de 100
millions escomptés
pour la seule année 2010 8 enfin les 250
millions d'euros restant à verser aux
régions titre du fonds exceptionnel créé
en 2017 vous seront bien versé en 2018
en revanche elle assume nous avons
décidé de ne pas intégrer le fonds
exceptionnel de 450 millions d'euros
dans le montant de la tva qui nous sera
alloué pour quoi d'abord parce que comme
son nom l'indiqué il s'agissait d'un
fonds exceptionnel que par nature
l'exception n'a jamais eu vocation à
devenir la règle
ensuite parce que je ne veux pas rentrer
dans une politique qui serait fondée sur
des chèques en blanc ou des chèques en
bois vous avez dit monsieur le président
et vous avez raison de le dire qu'il
convient lorsque l'on s'engage de tenir
ses engagements
au moins en tant que cela au moins
autant que cela il convient lorsque l'on
s'engage de me s'engager cas ce que l'on
peut tenir et j'entends bien engagé à ce
que je peux tenir
je pense que c'est aussi un élément de
la confiance avec le caractère direct
des échanges plus fondamentalement parce
que compte tenu des équilibres le
financement de cette mesure serait
intervenu au détriment d'autres
collectivités territoriales je pense au
département je pense aux communes france
aux intercommunalités et enfin et c'est
probablement plus important parce qu'au
fond nous avons fait les deux tiers du
chemin que vous escomptiez vous
attendiez 450 millions d'euros en 2018
l'état vous en garantie 300 millions en
aide sans dynamique de tva est le
complément de crédits du fonds
exceptionnel de 2017
après trois années de baisses
successives des dotations 1,6 milliard
d'euros sur la dgf entre 2013 et 2017
ça n'est pas rien surtout dans le
contexte budgétaire dans lequel nous
nous trouvons que je n'invente pas et
que vous connaissez et je me permets
d'insister la location d'une part de tva
c'est extrêmement moderne ces
précurseurs et ça peut annoncer des
choses ensuite
c'est un engagement significatif pour
l'état puisqu'il concerne une recette
importante pour nos finances publiques
je voudrais dire une dernière fois pour
qu'il n'y ait pas d'ambiguïté
les régions ne connaîtront pas de belz
net de leurs ressources en 2018
vous toucherez moins qu'escompté mais ce
sera plus qu'en 2017
avec qui plus est une dynamique de la
tva garanties sur toute la mandature
quant à la suite après 2018 besoins
auront l'occasion d'y revenir
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire à la
conférence nationale des territoires de
vous le dire aussi monsieur le président
que la fiscalité locale n'était à mes
yeux ni juste ni lisible ni efficace
nous devons donc réfléchir ensemble en
prenant le temps car ces sujets sont
complexes et toute modification peut te
crées des gagnants et des perdants
nous devons donc réfléchir ensemble dans
le cadre de la conférence nationale les
territoires à la modernisation de notre
système de fiscalité locale je pense
qu'il conviendra d'en discuter dans ce
contexte de la conférence nationale des
territoires mais aussi dans le contexte
bilatéral de la relation entre le
gouvernement et les régions et notamment
d'en parler à l'aune du pacte financier
que le gouvernement vous propose j'ai
beaucoup parlé de recettes voudrais
parler de dépenses et je reviendrai sur
le pacte financier en contrepartie de la
ressource fiscale dynamique et de la
visibilité sur la mandature les
collectivités territoriales les régions
mais en vérité toutes les
administrations publiques locales
sociale ou de l'état vont devoir
poursuivre leurs efforts et maîtriser
l'augmentation la progression la dépense
publique
en tout état de cause nous voulons le
faire non pas par une baisse aura beau
des dotations non pas par une
suppression
par une diminution ex ante et des
dotations mais par un mécanisme
contractuel qui nous permet d'encadrer
d'encadrer l'augmentation de la dépense
publique nous voulons faire en sorte que
ce mécanisme contractuel il ne soit pas
appliquée à toutes les collectivités
territoriales de france mais à celle qui
concentre les deux tiers de la dépense
publique locale 319 collectivités
territoriales concentre à elle seule les
deux tiers de la dépense publique locale
les régions les départements les agglos
métropole bien entendu les
agglomérations de plus de cent cinquante
mille habitants les villes de plus de 50
mille habitants pour les autres qui sont
souvent des petites villes qui
connaissent souvent des difficultés qui
sont parfois des villages souvent des
villages l'effort de maîtrise de la
dépense est indispensable et elles le
font d'emblée vous avez raison monsieur
le président on attend pas à la consigne
de l'état pour faire attention à la
gestion de l'argent public
mais reconnaissez avec moi que
l'évolution de la dépense publique
globalement et depuis de nombreuses
années collectivités territoriales et
états montrent que néanmoins malgré
toute cette attention comparé comporte à
la gestion des deniers publics
l'évolution par souvent est
manifestement à la hausse notre objectif
c'est de faire en sorte d'organiser avec
les 319 collectivités territoriales les
plus importantes pour la dépense
publique les objectifs de maîtrise de la
dépense et les mécanismes contractuels
de limitation de cette dépense publique
là encore ça ne veut pas dire que les
dépenses baisseront en valeur absolue
elles continueront à augmenter mais
cette augmentation doit se faire un
rythme contenu
concrètement si vous dépensiez cents en
il ne faudra pas à dépenser 101,2 en
c'est un effort réel mais je suis
convaincu qu'il est moins archaïque
et moins brutale qu'une baisse de
dotation par avance si j'ose dire
de même nous souhaitons que les
collectivités territoriales qui sont
dans une situation moins délicate que
les parents la matière j'en ai
parfaitement conscience mais que
néanmoins les collectivités
territoriales et l'ensemble des
administrations fixe des objectifs se
fixe des objectifs de désendettement et
des trajectoires de désendettement à
terme notre objectif c'est de vous aider
à dégager des marges d'autofinancement
pour investir durablement sur notre
territoire aux côtés de l'état
car la vocation d'un budget c'est
d'abord de servir une action c'est bien
pourquoi nous voulons au niveau des
collectivités recentrer les dépenses de
fonctionnement profit des dépenses
d'investissement vous êtes souvent sur
cette logique sur ses priorités
c'est vrai d'un très grand nombre de
collectivités territoriales mais c'est
indispensable pour le bien public et
c'est indispensable pour l'évolution de
notre pays au niveau de l'état
l'investissement de morale priorités
comme en témoigne le grand plan
d'investissements de 50 est de 57
milliards d'euros que nous avons
présentés avec jean pisani ferry en
début de semaine et qui fera une large
place aux régions nous voulons agir à
vos côtés en assurant la meilleure
complémentarité possible de nos actions
je serai très attentif dans le
déploiement de ce grand plan à ce que
une partie importante 10 milliards
d'euros puisse aller vers les
collectivités locales soient bien au
rendez vous de l'action publique et je
ne crois pas trahir un grand secret en
disant que les régions seront très
priante très prioritairement pardon
concerné dans le projet de plateforme
que voudrait que vous m'avez transmis
fin août
vous avez à juste titre identifié
plusieurs chantiers qui nous lie
directement
nous sommes prêts à travailler avec vous
nous devons même il travailler avec vous
les sujets ne manquent pas et pour ne
citer que quelques-uns d'entre eux je
voudrais évoquer la mobilité pour
laquelle nos destins sont liés dans les
réflexions sur une réforme réussie du
secteur ferroviaire notamment de
l'ouverture à la concurrence des thés
verts je pense aussi aux travaux engagés
dans le cadre des assises de la mobilité
avec la nécessité de penser services les
qualités avant de réfléchir
infrastructures et d'imaginer de
nouvelles formes de financement
lorsqu'on réfléchit aux infractions aux
infrastructures de transport
l'agriculture dont je reconnais bien
volontiers avec vous que nous avons des
progrès indéniables à faire en matière
de gouvernance le développement
économique des territoires où les
régions devront être associés au plan
d'action en faveur de la croissance des
entreprises portées par bruno le maire
et benjamin griveaux la transition
écologique ou la rénovation thermique
des bâtiments publics dans le cadre du
grand plan d'investissements et des
contrats de transition écologique porté
par sébastien lecornu n'aurait pas de
sens sans votre mobilisation
la politique de cohésion poste 2020 pour
laquelle nous devons travailler à
défendre au mieux les intérêts de nos
territoires auprès des instances
européennes
les outre-mer enfin auquel nous sommes
tous extrêmement attentifs et dont la
spécificité peut nourrir la réflexion
nationale en particulier sur
l'adaptation des normes
chacun de ces sujets mériterait un
développement si spécifique
nous aurons l'occasion d'en parler
ensemble permettez moi simplement de
prendre quelques instants pour évoquer
la question de la formation
professionnelle et de l'apprentissage
secteur dans lequel vous avez fait part
de votre souhait d'exercer un pouvoir
réglementaire locale vous le savez le
gouvernement va engager avec madame la
ministre du travail dans les semaines
qui viennent un exercice intense de
discussions de consultation le
négociations avec d'un côté les
organisations syndicales et patronales
qui sont
indispensable pour avoir une réflexion
pleine et entière en la matière et avec
de l'autre côté les régions qui par
leurs compétences par l'engagement
parfois même par leurs ambitions qui
sont parfois différentes d'une région à
l'autre en la matière et par leur
ambition concourt à ce sujet de la
formation professionnelle et de
l'apprentissage
notre objectif c'est après avoir modifié
le code du travail
après avoir modifié la fiscalité pour
favoriser l'investissement privé et pour
favoriser la croissance
c'est de réfléchir à la nouvelle façon
d'organiser l'apprentissage et la
formation professionnelle pour une
raison simple c'est que les compétences
et la capacité que l'on a à acquérir de
nouvelles compétences et à adapter en
permanence nos compétences sont
probablement les armes de destructions
les plus massives contre le chômage
c'est la compétence qui est au coeur de
la lutte contre le chômage
donc la formation initiale
c'est le travail du ministre de
l'éducation nationale l'apprentissage et
la formation professionnelle et nous
voulons entre le début du mois d'octobre
où ce processus de réflexion va être
engagée et la fin du mois de mars début
du mois d'avril où nous présentons un
projet de loi engager cette discussion
avec vous sur tous les sujets sur toutes
les initiatives sur toutes les
originalités
nous ne reproduirons jamais en france ce
qui marche parfaitement dans d'autres
pays il est convenu vous le savez tous
ici de se référer de façon systématique
à l'allemagne parfois au danemark sur la
question de l'apprentissage
la vérité c'est que les structures les
cultures de nos pays sont suffisamment
différentes pour qu'il soit
inenvisageable je dis ça à philippe
richert pour qu'il soit il envisageable
de les calques et complètement mais nous
pouvons nous en inspirer nous pouvons en
apprendre nous pouvons au moment où nous
redéfiniront les objectifs les tuyaux
financement les compétences nous pouvons
nous inspirer de ce qui fonctionne
ailleurs et c'est bien notre objectif
parce que en la matière il ne faut pas
escompter d'ailleurs heureusement
personne ne l'imaginent que l'état seul
puisse déterminer les formations les
plus utiles à tel endroit les meilleures
façons de développer l'apprentissage
dans tel ou tel secteur indispensable
c'est évidemment un travail de terrain
et dans ce travail de terrain les
organisations syndicales et patronales
et les régions on vous le savez un rôle
important
je voudrais également insisté sur un
point qui n'apparaît pas directement
dans votre projet de plate forme mais
qui est le rôle des régions dans la
cohésion des territoires
dans un environnement où les structures
administratives sont plus vastes du fait
de cette réforme des régions nous avons
un intérêt partagé à conforter le
maillage intermédiaires et le lien avec
les territoires
nous devons donc travailler de concert
pour soutenir des projets de territoire
dans le cadre des contrats de ruralité
par exemple aucun élu rural ne
comprendrai qu'aujourd'hui l'état et les
régions se fassent concurrence dans
l'accompagnement des territoires le
gouvernement jacques mézard et julien
gau normandie en premier lieu porte un
regard très attentif aux petites et aux
moyennes villes celle là même où se
concentre le sentiment d'abandon de
relégation l'abstention est parfois le
vote protestataire
là encore nous devons unir nos forces
pour répondre rapidement aux élus et
habitants de ces territoires qui se
sentent délaissés
à nous de les remettre au coeur de
l'attention politique j'ai indiqué ce
que nous ferions s'agissant du pacte
financier pour les petites communes
j'insiste aussi sur le fait que dans le
projet de budget 2010 8 nous maintenons
les dotations permettant de financer des
investissements dans le monde rural de
façon justement a indiqué cette
attention
un dernier mot avant de conclure vous
avez choisi pour thème de votre congrès
osons les expérimentations et bien voilà
un sujet sur lequel nos planètes sont
parfaitement alignés
le gouvernement a bien entendu votre
invitation à favoriser l'expérimentation
comme mode d'exercice des compétences
régionales
c'est l'esprit même du programme qui a
porté le président de la république
pendant sa campagne donner plus de
souplesse aux collectivités pour décider
de leur propre organisation
c'est ce que j'ai appelé pour ma part la
décentralisation assumé lors de la
conférence nationale des territoires de
juillet vous l'avez dit monsieur le
président et je vous rejoins volontiers
sur ce point il n'y aurait pas de sens à
vouloir rejouer le big bang de
l'organisation territoriale à vouloir
modifier depuis paris les limites de
telle ou telle circonscription régionale
ou de telle ou telle circonscription
départementale nous devons
collectivement digérer et avancer nous
laisserons orange une liberté aux
collectivités territoriales celle de
s'organiser comme elle pense le plus
utile et le plus efficace de s'organiser
si les départements veulent fusionner
dans le respect de ce que nous
apprécierons être l'intérêt général ils
pourront le faire si des communes
veulent accélérer le mouvement déjà
engagé de réunion elles pourront le
faire
et si et si nous pouvons favoriser
l'expérimentation de solutions locales
nous le ferons
c'est indispensable nous avons décidé
avec gérard collomb le ministre d'état
ministre de l'intérieur et avec
jacqueline gourault de saisir le conseil
d'état
d'une part sur l'âme la possibilité de
différencier les compétences au sein
d'un même groupe de collectivités ça
vous concerne directement
et d'autre part sur les modalités
d'exercice de ses compétences il s'agit
de questions très ouverte à partir
desquelles le conseil nous aidera à
préciser les tenants et aboutissants et
aboutissants du pouvoir de
différenciation et en tirer les
conclusions dans la perspective de la
prochaine conférence du territoire et
peut-être dans la perspective de la
prochaine réforme constitutionnelle
mesdames et messieurs dans un moment où
le gouvernement plaide pour une
décentralisation assumé je suis prêt à
jouer le jeu du dialogue et de la
concertation en disant les choses
directement en ne fermant aucune porte
et en étant toujours prêt au dialogue à
la fois avec chacun des présidents de
région et avec l'ensemble des régions en
tant que tel nous devons construire la
confiance ça ne veut pas dire que nous
devons être d'accord sur tout et nous ne
serons pas d'accord sur tout mais ça
veut dire que nous devons réussir à nous
parler de tout et a systématiquement
rechercher la meilleure solution pour
nos concitoyens
c'est en tout cas ainsi que je conçois
la relation privilégiée que vous appelez
de vos voeux avec l'état et c'est dans
cette dynamique que le président de la
république et moi même souhaitons nous
inscrire l'agenda des prochains mois
sera chargé il sera surtout je l'espère
l'occasion d'un travail utile et
constructif nous aurons des rendez vous
planifiés dans le cadre de la conférence
nationale des territoires dans le cadre
des assises de la mobilité dans celui
des états généraux de l'alimentation et
dans celui des assises de l'outre-mer
mais nous aurons aussi des consultations
sectorielles sur la formation
professionnelle et l'apprentissage jeu
ligne nous aurons également j'y tiens
des échanges individuels autant que
nécessaire et je vous propose de nous
retrouver en janvier 2018 dans le cadre
d'une rencontre bilatérale état région à
laquelle il associerait vos
interlocuteurs quotidiens ça va
les préfets de région pour faire un
point d'étape sur tous les sentiers que
j'ai évoqués mesdames et messieurs les
présidents de conseils régionaux
mesdames et messieurs vous avez indiqué
tout à l'heure monsieur le président du
conseil régional que vous étiez hier à
chambord et que vous feriez bientôt le
500e anniversaire de la première pierre
château de chambord 2010 est une année
d'anniversaire c'est l'année du
protestantisme le 500e anniversaire du
protestantisme s'est quasiment
l'anniversaire de la création du château
de chambord c'est le 500e anniversaire
de la création aussi d'une ville qui est
chère à mon coeur le havre je sais en
étant dans cette région centre val de
loire que je suis dans une région qui a
été marquée par la personnalité de
françois 1er
je sais que l'histoire aurait pu être
très profondément différente en fonction
de décisions qu'il a prises ou qu'il a
abandonné savez monsieur le président du
conseil régional que la capitale de la
france a failli être romorantin si si
françois 1er en 15/100 16 après avoir
accueilli léonard de vinci en france
après que celui ci franchit les alpes
avec notamment dans son sac la joconde
l'installer chez vous et amoureux qu'il
était du site de romorantin et a conçu
un projet considérable de construction
d'une ville nouvelle fondée sur des
canaux il avait même imaginé le
percement d'un canal ambitieux entre la
loire et la saône je le dis pour xavier
bertrand mais il n'est pas encore là
pardon je ne t'ai pas vu arriver
je salue le président du conseil
régional d autres ans le projet était
formidable et françois 1er ne l'a pas
réalisé ce qui est dommage pour mende
il ne l'a pas réalisé parce qu'il a
réaffecté ses objectifs en fonction de
l'évolution du monde tel qu'il est et il
a créé d'autres villes et il a décidé
d'ouvrir le royaume sur le grand large
parce que c'était là que la croissance
et la puissance se trouvait vous parle
pas de romorantin simplement pour le
plaisir d'évoquer la ville dans laquelle
la tarte tatin aînés je vous parle de
romorantin parce qu'elle montre que les
décisions prises par l'état sont
essentiels quelles sont cruciales et
qu'elles sont parfois difficile et
qu'elle engage et que j'ai parfaitement
conscience qu'elles peuvent heurter mais
la direction qui a été fixé par le
président de la république la direction
que j'assume pleinement cette en même
temps de remettre en ordre de nos
finances publiques de permettre le
redémarrage de la croissance dans notre
pays de faire en sorte de mettre en
oeuvre des politiques ambitieuses de
transformation des politiques publiques
dans les domaines où nous n'avons pas
les résultats que nous devrions obtenir
compte tenu des financements que nous
consentons c'est de faire confiance aux
collectivités territoriales c'est de
leur permettre d'oser
de travailler en confiance avec l'état
et de travailler en visibilité avec
l'état les discussions se poursuivront
monsieur le président vous m'avez redit
hier qu'on vient vous y étiez attachés
quelles étaient vos exigences je les
entends
elles seront discutées dans un cadre
sérieux dans un cadre crédible
je parle du gouvernement je n'ai aucun
doute sur la crédibilité de ce que vous
indiquez afin là encore de pouvoir nous
engager fermement sur des objectifs que
nous savons pouvoir tenir je remercie
mesdames et messieurs de votre attention
voilà ce discours des leurs philippe le
premier ministre qui a ouvert il ya
quelques minutes le congrès des régions
de france
le premier ministre qui a certes prôné
le dialogue entre l'état et les régions
mais qui était resté ferme sur ses
positions et pour réagir à ce discours
avec xavier bertrand le président de la
région de france bonjour et xavier
bertrand merci d'être avec nous vous
venez d'entendre ce discours des doigts
philippe à ce que le premier ministre a
répondu à vos attentes
certainement pas évidemment il vient
nous voir le premier ministre en disant
l'état avait pris avec vous deux
engagements la tva affectés et puis 450
millions d'euros pour vos nouvelles
compétences économiques
et bien soyez content on va tenir un
engagement sur les deux non mais vous
vous imaginer n'importe qui prendra un
engagement avec une autre personne
qu'est ce qui se passe à la relation
allait terminer on fait plus confiance
dans ces cas là et sur les 450 millions
d'euros il faut bien voir ça servait
pour les compétences économiques
on nous a dit vous aurez plus de pouvoir
économique et on va vous financer une
partie de ces nouvelles compétences
hélas au bout d'un an rideau terminé en
clair aujourd'hui nous nous retrouvons
avec des compétences alors on est
vraiment contents de les assumer parce
qu'on pense que le terrain c'est nous
qui la maîtrisons plus que l'état vu de
paris mais derrière les c'est terminé
nous n'avons plus les fonds affectés et
je vais vous dire tu en as marre parce
que dans tous les domaines c'est comme
ça voilà quelques mois on venait nous
voir est ce que vous pouvez pas prendre
des contrats aidés ce serait bien
aujourd'hui on nous dit ben non vous en
aurez moins y en a certains qui vont
s'arrêter sans prévenir ça a été la
baisse des dotations et on ne peut plus
du tout faire confiance alors je dis
très clairement c'est du mépris c'est du
mépris des collectivités locales parce
que c'est nous qui devons rendre des
comptes aux entreprises
c'est nous qui faisons des économies à
la différence de l'état ya aucune
collectivité locale aucune qui peut
voter un budget en déséquilibre c'est ce
que fait l'état depuis des dizaines et
des dizaines d'années c'est nous aussi
qui avons su faire de réduction de nos
dépenses
c'est nous aussi qui avons une réduction
de nos effectifs
quand l'état arrive timidement à le
faire alors qu'on arrête de nous donner
des leçons qu'on arrête de nous
engueuler et puis lors dans ces cas là
qu'on nous donne des libertés parce que
ce que j'ai bien compris c'est qu'on
n'aura plus jamais un euro en plus mais
alors qu'on nous laisse des libertés en
plus tiens apprentissage qu'on nous
laisse faire sur la réglementation en
lien et les partenaires sociaux
qu'est ce qui fait qu'un apprenti
boucher a 16 ans et un jour le couper la
viande est à 15 ans et 6 mois il n'a pas
le droit de le faire cette
réglementation elle est absurde
alors qu'on nous donne des libertés mais
ce qu'il faut voir c'est qu'aujourd'hui
on a un état qui nous dit bon on est
franchement on devait vous couper le
bras on vous coupe que la main dit merci
et ben non elle dansait plus possible
donc on est à la fin du chemin à la fin
du chemin entre l'état et les
collectivités locales
et il faut que ce soit redéfinie et la
question du dialogue le dialogue pour
rien dire et dialogues pour ja faire ça
ne sert à rien et je le vois moi sur
tous les sujets nous quand on donne
notre parole
peut-être parce que les plus proches des
gens pour certains on sait pertinemment
ce que c'est que la parole au delà de la
conception de l'honneur que l'on a mais
l'état n'a plus de paroles on sent
ventre votre colère et votre votre
ras-le-bol xavier bertrand aujourd'hui
le dialogue est rompu c'est ça qu'est ce
que vous allez faire avec l'état parce
que j'étais de l'autre côté de la
barrière j'étais pendant six ans et demi
ministre mon dieu je crois au rôle de
l'état dans un pays comme le nôtre pour
protéger ses la sécurité la justice la
défense
même ça il ne fait pas assez bien
malraux moins qu'ils arrêtent de
s'occuper de tout qu'il revienne sur ce
qu'il doit faire et pour le reste qu'ils
laissent faire ce qu'ils ont envie et
qui s'affairent les régions on a aussi
les agglomérations les métropoles les
communautés de communes mais je tiens
aussi à garder la place des miracles on
est en train de les étrangler les
mairies c'est un système terrible moins
hypocrite qui consiste à dire on va vous
donner de moins en moins comme ça vous
pourrez faire de moins en moins et au
final on éteindra la lumière mais qu'ils
assument leurs choix qu'il les assume
et encore une fois je pense qu'il va
falloir nous apprendre vraiment à nous
débrouiller sans l'état je pense que
tous les contrats de plan état région
qui ont été signés je pense que l'éthane
déshonorera pas je pense que sur les
cofinancements et on voit notamment avec
les assises de la mobilité qui sont en
train de préparer le couralin m les
prédécesseurs ont beaucoup promis on n'a
pas les moyens vous pensez bien c'est
des méchants avant nous non moi j'ai
toujours cru cru notamment quand j'étais
ministre que la parole de l'état elle
était plus importante que les
gouvernements qui se succédaient voilà
ce à quoi je croyais moi je pense qu'il
faut que je révise mes classiques
si on vous entend le dialogue entre
l'état et les régions est rompu qu'est
ce que doit faire l'êta selon vous
qu'est ce que vous lui demandez
concrètement pour renouer ce lien qui
nous foutent la paix qu'ils arrêtent de
nous mettre des bâtons dans les roues
qu'il arrête quand il ya une
implantation d'entreprise de nous sortir
toutes les réglementations du monde et
parfois en les interprétant de la façon
la plus stricte qui soit qu'ils nous
laissent faire sur la formation
professionnelle
qu'ils arrêtent de nous changer les
règles une fois tous les 6 mois regarder
notamment sur les contrats d des
libertés et de l'autonomie et je ne vous
cache pas que dans les hauts de france
c'est ce que je suis en train de
préparer et je préférerais que ce soit
discuté négocié avec l'état
ou alors il faudra rentrer dans un vrai
rapport de force vous savez quand vous
êtes méprisés comme nous le sommes
au final vous pouvez plus dans un vrai
dialogue c'est dommage c'est vraiment
dommage mais je pense qu'on en est
arrivé là et sur plein de sujets nombre
de maires pourraient vous dire
aujourd'hui ils ont des dossiers faut
quasiment les refaire je vous jure que
je n'exagère pas c'était en tirages
d'autres jours faut refaire parce que le
formulaire a été mal rempli mais comme y
sera pas rendue dans les temps le
financement va tomber et ceux qui sont
le plus gêné c'est les représentants de
l'état qui savent ce qu'on leur impose
aux que la pieuvre technocratique impose
parce que la première technocratique
elle pense que les collectivités locales
sont bonnes à rien qu'elles sont juste
bonnes à dépenser 90 ch dame là haut
nous on est prêt du terrain et je vous
assure qu'on fait vraiment notre mieux
et nous on sait compter
la goutte d'eau qui a fait déborder le
vase de votre colère si je puis dire
c'est cette annonce de suppression du
fonds de 450 millions d'euros pour le
développement économique est ce que vous
demandez au premier ministre de revenir
dessus de vous leur donnez sasa apaisera
peut-être votre colère lui reviendra pas
dessus on l'a compris il est là nous
dire vous vous rendez compte ce qu'on
vous avait promis en 2017
on va vous le donner et il faudrait
sauté sur l'echez applaudira tournure
génial merci
non mais ça va quoi ça va et pour 2018
vous pensiez avoir quelque chose vous
aurez rien d'accord et encore on est
poli épaules et claudie par politesse
mais pour le reste ça veut dire qu'on
peut plus travailler avec eux
il vous a quand même maintenu la
remplace le remplacement de la dotation
globale de fonctionnement par une part
de la tva que vous avez accordé manuel
valls ça c'est quand même une bonne
chose est ce que vous n'avez pas
l'impression d'en demander un petit peu
trop xavier bertrand dans le contexte
actuel c'est pas moi qui ai promis à la
fois le fond pour les compétences
économiques et l'affectation d'une parle
c'est pas moi qui ai promis ce que vous
avez eue l'an dernier on va dire merci
chaque année c'était une dure
négociation et pourquoi c'était dur
négociations parce qu'on nous faisait
les poches chaque année chaque anneau
faisait les poches
donc ça ça a été acquis mais pourquoi
pas pour nous faire plaisir pas pour
faire une cagnotte pour les régions pour
qu on le dépense intelligemment sur le
transport sur les lycées sur l'économie
l'emploi la formation et sur les autres
compétences qui même si elles ne sont
pas obligatoires sur lesquels on
intervient donc encore une fois c'est
pas un cadeau qui a été fait c'était
juste d'avoir des règles du jeu sable
visiblement celle là vont être respectés
d'accord très bien je pas non plus
claquer les pétards et sortir le
champagne en disant merci vous avez tenu
parole à 50% mais le reste quand vous
avez quelqu'un qui régulièrement revient
sur ce qu'il dit c'est vous pouvez plus
lui faire confiance
un dernier mot et xavier bertrand sur le
canal seine-nord emmanuel macron et son
gouvernement a annoncé une pause dans
les grands projets d'infrastructure
emmanuel macron sera dans votre région
mardi à l'usiné whirlpool damien est ce
que vous craignez que le canal
seine-nord sa menace et qu'est ce que
vous allez dire au président de la
république
mais déjà il veut pas en parler pour
l'instant projets qui touchent la région
d'origine il en avait parlé pourtant
c'était le 3 mars dernier sur rtl il
avait dit alors le lyon turin et le
canal seine-nord alors là ces deux
projets là il peut rien leur arriver
et patatras il a laissé faire une pause
qui pour le canal peut être mortel parce
que l'europe commence à nous direz vous
les français ça commence à bien faire
il ya deux milliards d'euros on était
prêt à faire visiblement vous n'avez pas
envie leur nous on va vous les reprendre
et le gouvernement c'est ça très bien
présidence et ça très bien et ils jouent
la montre pour tuer le canal pour tuer
le canal
nous avions rencontré la ministre des
transports voilà bientôt trois semaines
elle nous avait dit d'accord pas de
problème on va réunir le conseil de
surveillance les groupes travail dès la
semaine prochaine
c'était là quinze jours les groupes de
travail qu'il rien depuis silence radio
on les appelle tout ça silence radio
mais encore une fois c'est du mépris
c'est du mépris
elle a pris des engagements réunion ils
ne sont pas tenus
et donc je vous le dis nous nous avons
provoqué provoquer leur c'est pas
habituel c'est vrai avec les présents de
conseils départementaux on est tous sur
la même ligne
quelles que soient les sensibilités
politiques et on convoque le conseil de
siaugues canal amiens mardi prochain
c'est une coïncidence bien sûr que non
nous le faisons ce jour là et on va voir
si l'état bien si l'état ne vient pas
c'est vraiment un abandon du projet à
l'issue nous avons appelé au
rassemblement un rassemblement calme
très responsable de centaines de maires
de la région pour dire au président de
la république nous voulons être reçus et
nous voulons entendre non seulement la
confirmation que le canal se fait en
temps et en heure mais qu'ils répondent
à nos questions
est ce que oui ou non ils acceptent
qu'on paye à la place de l'état les
premières années est-ce qu'ils acceptent
qu'on garantisse l'emprunt et est-ce
qu'ils acceptent que le projet de canal
soit maintenant régionaliser les
ministres ont dit oui nous voulons
entendre de la part du présent et qu'il
nous donne une méthode qui lui
garantissent qu'il sera fait et comme on
n'arrive pas à se faire entendre comme
on n'arrive pas à se faire comprendre
c'est malheureux mais il faut que l'on
demande aux élus de se rassembler en fin
de matinée devant l'hôtel de région pour
commencer ensuite devant la préfecture
là où viendra le pré on la république
pour un déjeuner républicain mais moi
j'ai pas envie de déjeuner si on ne
répond pas à nos questions le problème
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il faut qu'on
arrête les convenances faut qu'on arrête
les habitudes les discours on
s'applaudit quand on riait n'a été dit
ou on fait semblant 2 les gens font pas
semblant eux de connaître la difficulté
les gens font pas semblant quand ils
réclament de l'espoir ce projet donne de
l'espoir et encore une fois c'est un
projet qui sort de nulle part il a été
garanti par l'état garanti par l'état je
veux juste savoir si la parole d'un
président de la république ça compte
merci
voilà pour cette réaction de xavier
bertrand enregistré il ya quelques
minutes ici à orléans le président de la
région de france vous l'avez entendu
qu'il ya eu des mots très durs pour
réagir au discours d'edouard philippe le
premier ministre qui est venu ce matin
ouvrir ce congrès des régions de france
alors il a certes prôné le dialogue avec
les régions mais il n'est pas revenu sur
la suppression du fonds de développement
économique de 450 millions d'euros
prévus dans le budget 2010 8 ce fonds
qui a été alloué aux régions par manuel
valls
l'année dernière qui est donc supprimé
dans le budget un véritable casus belli
pour les régions et d'un philippe est
resté ferme a maintenu ses positions
nous continuerons à vous faire vivre
cette journée ce congrès des régions de
france ici à orléans on se retrouve à
partir de 15 heures d'antenne à 360 pour
la suite et puis on aura à notre micro
philippe richert tu le président des
régions de france président de la région
grand est qui viendra donc en direct à
réagir à notre micro est lui aussi à ce
discours d' edouard philippe
merci à tous de nous avoir suivis à tout
à l'heure
[Musique]
c